this thing is
quite large and quite sticky taped damn
it scissors i did bring them
wow look at this
a giant box
anybody have any guesses for what this
could be anybody if you guess correctly
i'll give you pizza it is not a ps5 i
wish
you're right it's a lamp okay so i got
this lovely package in the mail
from bear walker
and this is something that um i've been
really really really excited to open
because it's to me
an art form without
like
being a traditional art if that makes
any sense we have the box open oh my god
this is so big it's so hard to unbox
things in my stupid tiny setup
it's so cool look at it
this piece of foam
is that what you expected is how you
thought it was going to be it's a nice
piece of foam this is beautiful
i need you to understand
here
you go
how
freaking cool is this
so
if you don't already know him um bear
walker is an artist who makes
skateboards effectively very nice art on
skateboards
and this is the um 25th anniversary
pokemon
um
pikachu
what they call it pikachu 25
pikachu 25th
celebration um skateboard from uh in
partnership with bear walker and the
pokemon center so bear walker sent this
one to me
um because i've been in his dms bugging
him
to see
if he uh knew of anybody who had the
charizard one which i've been trying to
track down but this just came out
and is incredible look how cool it is
it's also this is all like textured and
i love the way that it goes from from
dark and it kind of fades upwards you
know
it's beautiful i'm such a big fan
and then on the back here
you get your little pikachu 25 symbol
they've been using bear walker is his
name of course
pokemon center
made in the usa
um so naturally it is a skateboard so
you can
actually connect your bearings and your
wheels and all that good stuff but i'm
not going to i intend to use this
as a piece of art that i would hang
somewhere um
i just think it's so
nice and would look beautiful displayed
on a wall it's also just always really
nice to get something that is like
clearly
handmade with love like you can see the
the way the paint is faded out on all
this and
there's like little pink bits and
pikachu's cheeks and the pink or the red
on the the top of the um pokeball there
yeah it's textured this is like really
like kind of spiky
it's beautiful oh that one's a they're
different kinds of pokeballs i just
realized
i wasn't paying attention they're all
different kinds of pokeballs
got a master ball
beautiful very very very nice but that's
not all
we also have
the wheels
so it actually comes with these
pokemon center
hyperium
wheels for your skateboard
which is awesome
watch out
it's an entire skateboard but i really
don't want to write it
i get that you technically can
but i have no intention of doing so um
we also have
because i used to escape like a little
bit i don't know what half of the stuff
is
plastic pieces uh
skateboards they come
with plastic spaces for the trucks there
you go
and then it comes with a whole bunch of
screws in there as well so you can
actually assemble it um i am going to
keep all this stuff like i think even
having
like skateboard wheels
that say pokemon center on them is a
really cool thing to to be able to have
i just think that that's so neat but
yeah my intent is to use it as an art
piece it's so so so cool and i've been
following
uh bear walker
on instagram for a while now because i
just think he's he's super super
talented and makes so much awesome stuff
and it has a bunch of instructions for
how to actually make it a skateboard but
um no i i definitely intend to use it as
an art piece
let's uh check if they're still
available shall we here it is
i think that it's home and home office
is how it's described
pokemon santa x bear walker pikachu 25th
celebration skateboard
um
this might have better detail than my
bad webcam that's what it looks like all
assembled
yeah
it's beautiful i'm so stoked to have
this ah
look at it that's gonna that could be me
yeah
so it is 250 looks like it's still in
stock
purchase limit of one um because it is a
limited edition though i'm not sure if
it says
what kind of limit so it says there are
plenty of exciting ways to celebrate 25
years of pokemon and this custom
designed special edition pikachu
skateboard by bear walker is here to get
things rolling
nice cause it's a skateboard handcrafted
from maplewood wow this 29-inch cruiser
board features a grip pattern for
durability and ride ability no grip tape
necessary that makes sense i was
mentioning the texture when i opened it
up it comes complete with premium trucks
and wheels for a smooth ready to go ride
or if you'd rather show off the awesome
pokemon design at home the board can be
mounted to a wall with a hanging mount
not included so that's what i'll need to
look into getting is the hanging mount
because that's how i intend to use it uh
artistic design features pikachu in mid
leap with a collection of different
pokeballs in the background natural
maple wood accents complement a bold
pokemon design built-in textured surface
provides a sturdy grip fully functional
board comes equipped with matching
wheels and trucks made by bear walker
exclusively for the pokemon center to
celebrate 25 years of
pokemon it's beautiful and it smells
really nice he's done loads of these
loads of the the pokemon ones and having
the 25th anniversary of um pokemon one
is really cool because obviously pokemon
has been like a massive part of my life
like i'm so happy to have something
just as a token of the anniversary just
in general that that rules um
but he also yeah has a charizard and a
gyarados for the other two that i really
wanted because they're my two favorites
um but it is beautiful so a very very
very very big thanks to bear walker for
sending this over to me
i'm in love with it like
even he's in love with it look at him
iron it off it's mine but yeah they they
end up going for quite a bit because
they are collector's items so i'll have
to ask him like how how limited it is if
it is limited i just assume so because
he can only make a certain amount but he
also um just released
look at more of them right oh wall mount
i should buy that
um
the piplup just came
out oh mango so cute
and
yeah it's genesect just came out too
these are just so nice and then you've
got all your sold out ones through here
so this is the charizard that i've been
trying to track down
look at how cool that is
it's incredible
so i'm trying to find one that isn't
ten thousand dollars because that uh
duh
the pose i love it uh i'm such a sucker
for uh for a cool design
this uh pikachu one's really cool too oh
i'm not a rabbit i promise a little
angry pg let him go and then
here it is the gyarados that i also
really love and would absolutely
display
but
yeah we've got
a whole bunch of them in here the gengar
is really neat rayquaza that's a really
cool pose too i mean the mewtwo dude
dude not that mew's not all so cool but
they're literally all sorted out togepi
and
toxicity
that is so sick
mu's always a cutie
gengar i love that cheeky face on him
god damn it
god damn it
i just think that these are
incredibly cool
so yeah um
just thought that i would show that off
i i intend to um again he sent me this
this 25th edition of pikachu which i'm
super thankful i'll leave a link in the
description if you're watching this on
youtube where you can check those out
but i'm trying to track down which i
would be paying for myself of course
um the gyarados and the charizard and
the idea is that i'll have them on a
wall like all next to each other and
i'll buy that display mount too i didn't
realize that they had them as well um
which is awesome
so
yeah thank you for watching i'll see you
guys next time bye
unless you're on twitch in which case
i'm not going anywhere just yet